christian season 11 of halloween wars
premieres sunday on the food network and
we have a local contestant on the show
holly webster back here in the kitchen
with us we started making our halloween
cupcakes and and how am i doing here so
far well
don't quit your day job
i'm going to keep designing my cupcakes
yours look amazing tell us more about
the show because zach bacon is involved
this season how's he involved he is well
it was a surprise to us we were on set
and he literally appeared on a tv screen
oh my gosh oh yeah the lights start
blinking so they just set up this spooky
ambiance and he starts telling us what
he wanted to what we needed to do for
the challenge and it's a team of three
it is now do you know your team members
going into the contest we are complete
strangers um from all over the united
states
and uh so luckily we had a great dynamic
um my teammate amy my teammate cortarius
from florida and from mississippi
uh so yeah and it's a process of
elimination and you tell me this is one
of the highest rated shows on the food
network it is
it is it's crazy because it's 11 seasons
this show it's been on for a long time
it's a great show but what i love too is
you've been to zac's museum he has some
crazy things there and so you're making
designs based on something from his
museum or something from his past yes
so like he'll like he came up with this
craziest stuff literally spine chilling
so he gave us the directive and we had
to figure out how to incorporate that
kind of spook factor into our design can
you i don't know if you can tell me this
you're telling me this off here but did
something did you feel some presence on
the set oh my gosh
yeah
there were the weirdest things that
happened because this stuff is haunted
no i know and so we were actually
working and some of the oven doors just
flew open no i'm not kidding i'm not
kidding we all kind of looked like we
thought it was a setup like just to
scare us if if our oven door opens up
i'm out i am out of the studio
and we thought it was a setup and we
kind of looked around the producers are
like no actually we didn't do that so
yeah what what inspired you to do the
show i mean it's such a great show
you're such an amazing uh baker thank
you what inspired you to do it um you
know what it's one of those shows that
to be on halloween wars is a huge huge
honor because they focus a lot on
artistry so you really have to have a
skill set in order to actually get cast
for the show okay um what do we make
your day what is this design you and i
love it we can chitchat all afternoon
but as we're chitchatting we're making
something i don't know we're just gonna
do some really fun halloween cupcakes to
get people in the mood and we gotta make
sure that people watch a show sunday can
you take your cupcake out and hold it up
and i know where we can get a shot of it
somehow um to hold it up to see you know
here's an expert from from
halloween wars and then compared to my
little design i definitely think you're
the winner here you're fantastic though
thank you thank you but you won the las
vegas now championship
thank you so much we appreciate it and
halloween wars airs on food network this
sunday at 6 p.m holly thank you so much
las vegas now we'll be right back